[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL GRACHANIN:
Hey, everybody.
My name is Daniel Grachanin.
I'm the Cloud Gaming
Product Manager.
And today I want to talk to
you about something really
important to us at Cloud
for Game Developers,
telling your virtual story
and giving you the technology
to do that and scaling
and making your world
on a virtual cloud.
So a lot of it requires kind
of building outside the box.
And I want to first
kind of go back
through the history of how
we went from all the way
back to cave paintings to
current generation technology
and next-generation technology,
which will actually allow us
to make immersive
technologies have
these massive, scaleable worlds.
So, from its inception,
cave paintings
were actually used
as a way to tell you
the limit of your world.
They were made to say, there
are predators, so don't go here,
or the "here be dragons"
type of situation.
Moving on, we moved on
to actually written text
that was put onto boxes
or, actually, tablets.
So that would be your
box in that situation.
There was no audio.
There was no visual.
It was just completely
written text.
We moved on to things like
the Gutenberg Bible, which
was made by the printing press.
And then you actually had
distributed, scalable books
or stories.
This moves on to the TV,
which is great except for it
lacked audio.
So we added visual
with it and audio.
We brought it together.
And we developed our
first video game,
which was called
"Noughts and Crosses"
back in the early '40s.
Moving on, there was
the second-- technically
the first-- video game,
which was called "Space War."
The problem with
"Space War" is it was
associated with this hardware.
So this game was completely
tied to its hardware.
It didn't scale.
If you didn't have this box and
the visual and the game itself,
there was no way to just
have more of these games.
That's where the
console generation
began with a mix of lots
of different consoles.
But Atari is the most popular
one that's recognized.
What Atari did is
allow you to have
a console and different
stories, if you will,
with these cartridges.
You could use the
cartridge, have
it play "Asteroids"
in this case,
play "Dig Dug" or
something else like that.
So I want to talk about this and
kind of go into the technology
that was from the past and
how we've moved into where
we're going to the future.
Essentially what this
did is, as I said,
the console-cartridge
relationship
made everything
kind of localized
but it at least
gave you the chance
to have different experiences
in different games.
A save feature, which was
actually implemented back
in '87 with "The
Legend of Zelda,"
allows you to actually
have a continued story.
That way you can actually take
a picture of it, if you will.
But that was only associated
with the character.
And that was only limited by
as large as a game could be,
which, back then,
was very small.
There was no generation.
It had limited instructions.
And it was, again, limited to
your on-premise local machine.
Not to mention that
matchmaking probably
consisted of you having your
friend use your Mad Catz
controller and plug it
in for said Player 2.
So the current generation
of technology--
how we're doing matchmaking and
server technology and scaling
worlds--
is the client-server
model, which
Mark was kind of going
over just a second ago.
The problem with this is
it had stateful services.
These services are associated
with whatever the character is
doing or your client is
with the server, which
means they're bounded together.
What this does is it makes a
kind of a theme park reset.
So if you play
"World of Warcraft,"
you go into an
instance and it'll
be this great,
immersive experience.
But when you come back
out, you go back in
and it's a theme park reset.
There's no actual world
being distributed and scaled
and persistent.
So a lot of this was also
leveraged by currently
on-premise data centers.
So this is where we
kind of go into what
I want to talk
about today, which
is the next-generation
technology
of the entity-component
model, which was made famous
in early '70s.
The thing with this model is
we didn't have cloud computing
technology to scale all this.
So recently we're
partnering with a company
called Improbable.
And they have this technology
called Spatial OS, which
allows you to make distributed
operating systems in the cloud.
What it does is, the whole
entire concept of client
physics and logic, It separates
out into many workers.
These workers can
then individually
scale and make massively
scalable worlds
that are actually persistent.
Which is to say,
the world is living
when you're not playing
it, and you can still
live when you come
into the game.
It makes stateless
services, allows
for actual procedural
generation.
You can actually have
worlds that actually
keep scaling and scaling--
technically limitless,
as long as you
can afford the cloud bill.
And also it gives you the
ability to leverage the cloud.
The game called "Worlds Adrift"
built on their technology.
What this allows you to
do is have actual worlds
whenever you're going
to interact with it,
since you've separated all these
dynamics of client and logic
and physics.
If this ship crashes
into that actual planet
or that structure, it will
be destroyed in the world.
It won't reset.
It'll actually have a story to
itself, the whole entire world.
Why this is interesting
to us is it allows us
take snapshots of these states.
It allows us to do logging
and real-time telemetry on it.
And it lets us make
machine-learning models
out of that.
So when you're watching a game
like the "League of Legends"
Tournament last year
for 2016 or 2017,
it allows you to go back and see
how you would have done in that
situation by
associating AI models--
machine-learning models--
because you have these
persistent worlds
that are constantly generated.
Another thing we're
doing, too, is
looking at leveraging chipsets,
so physics and your logic
and client using
graphics-processing units, CPU,
and your TPUs, which
will be coming out soon.
What is interesting
about that is
it allows you to actually
have games at scale
and then, depending on
the hardware you're using,
it won't matter,
because you can have
games that can scale forever.
And it won't matter about
the technology you're using.
So we'll actually be
talking more about what
Mark Mandel talked about--
game server scaling,
big data analytics.
And as far as the
improbable relationship
we have for that
Spatial technology,
if you're interested,
please approach us, myself
or Mark Mandel.
And I will be
followed by Wouter.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]